okay
what's going on guys this is rob i got
mariah my fiance here we're gonna do a
reaction to the spiderman trailer i'm so
excited
[Music]
okay spiderman no way home i'm sorry i'm
i'm really excited i'm sorry i'm really
just i'm really excited okay okay
are you ready
yes okay
she's like the avatar fan she's like the
avatar fan okay
okay so let us watch this let's let us
watch this trailer okay
[Music]
oh look at this this is a good one some
suggest that parker's powers include the
male spider's ability to hypnotize
females
stop come on yes my spider lord
can we just like stay up here all day it
is so crazy down there
that's right folks spiderman is in fact
peter parker listen i did not kill
mysterio the drones did the drones that
are yours
[Music]
does any part of you feel relieved about
all this what do you mean
now that everybody knows you don't
really have to hide or lie to people for
the record i never wanted to lie to you
but how do you tell someone that you're
spiderman
[Music]
now everybody
but this isn't about me this is hurting
a lot of people
i've just been thinking about how to fix
all of this
so peter
so why do i owe the pleasure i'm sorry
i'm sir please we're safe to have the
universe together i think we're beyond
you calling me sir okay
stephen
that feels weird but i'll allow it
when mysterio revealed my identity my
entire life got screwed up
i was wondering if maybe you could make
it so that he never did
strength don't cast that spell
it's too dangerous
fine
i won't
oh no the entire world is about to
forget that peter parker spider-man wait
everyone
can't some people still know that's not
how the spell works
so mj's gonna forget about everything
we've ever been through stop tampering
with the spell oh my god ned he's my
best friend my aunt may should really
[Music]
oh crap
what just happened
we tampered with the stability of
space-time
multiverse is a concept about which we
know frighteningly level
the problem is you trying to live two
different lives
the longer you do it the more dangerous
it becomes
be careful what you wish for parker
hello
[Music]
i know
the possibilities
that trailer was amazing
dude this movie's gonna be insane
oh my
god
[Music]
that movie's going to be so good oh my
god it's going to be so good
america that movie is going to be
amazing
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm so excited just
those two end clues alone just let you
know
oh my god
yes it is
well
how to let you theorize
that's probably gonna be about half an
hour
okay okay anyway uh yes so we need to do
a video where we run over the
whole thing about what we think is gonna
happen with uh spider-man we gotta we
gotta make a video about that because
okay i think i know
look james i think i know
i think i know what's happening in this
movie
i think i know what the plot of this
movie is
let's make a video